it was the courtroom battle that became
a media circus two footballers wives
slugging it out over a social media post
and putting their reputations on the
line with the judge finally deciding
wagatha wasn't wrong
for colleen rooney it's relief and
vindication
but for rebecca vardy the worst of all
outcomes
reacting to the judgment she said i
brought this action to vindicate my
reputation and i'm devastated by the
judge's finding she got it wrong and
this is something i cannot accept
it's a catastrophic defeat for bhagavadi
because not only
is there the
you've been found to be a liar
label around her neck but her ability
then to go and appear on television and
do endorsements all that kind of thing i
suspect has been massively impaired
so how did this former friendship fall
apart well it goes back to 2019 when
stories from rooney's private instagram
like this car crash ended up in the sun
rooney suspected vardy of leaking them
so became an amateur sleuth planting
fake stories about gender selection and
a flooded basement which were only
visible to vardy when they appeared in
the paper too rooney pointed the finger
her post detailing her detective work is
how the name wagathi christie was born
revealing with dramatic effect it's
rebecca vardy's account
vardy sued for libel claiming serious
harm to her reputation and she suffered
online abuse but the case came down to
who was telling the truth the judge's
assessment of rebecca vardy and her
evidence was about as damning as you
could get she called it inconsistent
evasive and said it needed to be treated
with considerable caution that's a
polite way of saying i think you're
lying and so in trying to protect her
reputation rebecca vardy has actually
damaged it a whole lot more
and she faces a hefty bill too up to
three million pounds in legal fees that
could so easily have been avoided
rooney's team reportedly tried to settle
as many as four times
she did you know reach out to rebecca to
try to come and solve this in some way i
even offered to say look have a have a
few proseccos and some nuts so let's
just sort this out because it costs
millions such a waste of money the case
has shown an uncomfortable spotlight on
the nature of celebrity and the conflict
between courting publicity and
protecting privacy this former editor of
the sun is now a media advisor social
media is a fantastic tool to communicate
with fans and followers you know but
it's also very very dangerous you know
particularly combined with alcohol with
a late night tweet you know can end a
career sort of overnight within seconds
even
in this case it was the person who
posted who came out on top but social
media was still at the heart of
another's downfall with vardy suggesting
she won't appeal saying the case is over
iva bennett sky news